shakira risque huit ans de prison pour
fraude fiscale elle est accusée par le
parquet de barcelone de ne pas avoir
déclaré 14.5 millions d'euros entre les
années 2012 et 2014 selon l'accusation
la chanteuse colombienne de 45 ans
vivait en espagne depuis 2011 l'année où
sa relation avec gérard piqué
footballeur du fc barcelone a été rendu
public mais elle avait maintenu sa
résidence fiscale aux bahamas qui sont
considérés comme un paradis fiscal
depuis 2015 ses avocats eux estiment que
la plus grande partie de ses revenus
provenaient de ses tournées
internationales et qu'elle ne vivait pas
plus de six mois en espagne la condition
pour établir sa résidence fiscale dans
le pays jacques chirac clame son
innocence refuse tout accord et se dit
vouloir aller jusqu'au procès par
ailleurs elle a déclaré avoir déjà versé
17,2 millions d'euros au fisc espagnol
et qu'elle n'a donc plus aucune dette à
l'égard du trésor public depuis de
nombreuses années le nom de l'artiste
figurait déjà dans les pins doha papers
la vaste enquête de 2021 sur l'évasion
fiscale de plusieurs centaines de
personnalités